did you hear it
someone else is in this house
it's not only a murder mystery but
there's also a supernatural element to
the film which takes it to another level
actually Christie was an incredible
Storyteller she is the world's number
one mystery writer because she
understood a good detective story
Orient Express dealt with Revenge death
on the Nile dealt with greed this film
is about whether there is anything
beyond us a ghost a God where the horror
believes in it it involves him and us
being scared
it was a very clever plot I thought it
was my own life
she came back to tell me that she was
murdered
Dennis conjures up ideas of fantasy and
a sort of Darkness
gorgeous Relic slowly
stick your mind without a challenge
these actors had no warning about what
would happen what we did with lights
when doors opening
[Music]
I've never been on a set like this
before
there's a great sense of authenticity
it will be a proper thrill for the
audience
going to the police
the limb
your cute boy always on the case
[Music]
this film will bring audiences right to
the edges of their seat
[Music]
expect the unexpected